[Music]
you were just i'm told at comic-con yeah
okay i imagine my voice well i can
imagine i lost my voice i would imagine
that you at comic-con you're you must be
a god to comic-con people
you know just think about it i mean yeah
the rings were huge there's a lot of
fans of those those films people dress
up as those characters yeah so
elijah wood at comic-con you go there
and we're talking about very intense
fans do they do they
first of all
what do you do when you see them to try
and uh calm them down well i see i
haven't walked the floor until the first
time that i went which was about 10
years ago right so i haven't been able
to and all this time i keep thinking i'm
gonna walk the floor i'll just get a
mask or something so this year i got a
mask
um but it was sort of notionally a mask
in the sense that it was only half a
mask what mask was it it was a batman
mask oh oh you didn't wear cause a lot
some people put on like a darth vader
helmet which would have been way smarter
yeah except when i do it they see like a
six foot five darth vader walking around
with freckled hands because the body
gives you away but uh you know sadly it
does sticking out we have we have a
picture of you in the mask and i'm
thinking like yeah this
they're probably not a mask it's a cowl
oh my god i thought i was going to have
an aneurysm
it's a cowl okay sorry andy we hit a
nerve he's a real dark knight fanatic uh
we uh it is the problem you can tell
that that's just elijah wood dressed as
batman right
[Applause]
right is that what happened you're right
to people yeah it kind of didn't really
work so i was walking around
and i noticed that initially it was i
was free and clear i was walking looking
at things kind of keeping a regular pace
i didn't trust it didn't trust the mask
and then no one was saying anything this
is fantastic i can actually walk around
and then i start hearing rumblings as
i'm walking i'm like no no it's totally
not working but they were not coming up
to me because i had the mask on they
thought they'll be respectful of my
privacy clearly i have it on because i
want to be incognito
but it didn't really work no and then
people ask for photos and i was like i
gotta get to the water booth there's
been a crime i have to
the joker must be stopped
now i'm told that you have uh one of the
the actual lord of the rings rings one
of the the real rings that was used in
the movie
that you have one and i'm thinking that
must be
the ultimate
uh
prop to blow a fan's mind right this is
true but i've never i would never bring
it out primarily because it's it's it's
of great importance to me and i actually
keep it in a crawl space in my house
you've just told us where it is
i think you'll be changing that location
the location is changing this evening
yeah as we speak it's changing
uh okay so i would think in your shoes
if i was you and i had that ring and i
was out i would show that ring to the
ladies and i would i'm sorry that's me i
would
i would say look what i got you know
oh this so it's the one ring that rules
them all yeah exactly
like a great nerdy pickup line is that
is that how you would pick up chicks
nerdy what are you talking about
[Applause]
that's the coolest thing i could think
of
what are you talking about nerdy no i
would i totally would just come back to
the hotel i
another the ring ring you know we can
the original got
take it to mordar if you know what i
mean
and then i'll take you tomorrow
which doesn't mean anything um